Generally,
it's the attitude with which humor is
towed,
which I enjoy
that little bit of slapstick comedy by
the Great Rowan Atkinson is as simple as
it gets.
Unsuspecting man walks into a tree.
It's probably the most famous bit from
the late 1970 [inaudible] sketch show
that Atkinson starting called not the
9:00
news and what elevates it beyond a
simple joke is the same thing that makes
Atkinson one of the world's most gifted
physical comedians attitude.
I mean,
look at this sweet little man noticing a
camera being self conscious at first,
but just at the moment he starts to feel
a little bit special.
He's undercut.
Atkinson has the chops of the very best
physical comedians like Charlie Chaplin,
Buster Keaton or shock dot,
but what sets them apart I think is this
natural gift for characterization.
Nonverbal characterization,
not just the ability to do funny things
physically,
but the ability to use that physicality
to broadcast and attitude.
The things that make me laugh on
characters,
you know,
it's people who kind of present a sort
of truth to.
I mean,
even though it's mad or it's funny or
it's wacky or it's rude or it's or it's
silly,
but there's a sort of a truth there that
you identify with.
Of course,
most people know Atkinson as Mr Bean,
the globally famous character he created
who's mostly wordless antics,
call back to the visual comedy of silent
films.
Most Americans probably know him from
the being feature films that came later,
but the original Sitcom which ran for
only 15 episodes across six years is
where the best being work is.
That's generally because the more
cinematic the format,
the less interesting Mr.
Bean becomes.
Atkinson doesn't need much more than the
single two shot to work wonders.
Unlike Chaplin Keaton,
Atkinson isn't a director.
He's a performer through
this is hell no,
I am the devil.
Good evening,
but you couldn't call me toby if you
like.
We tried to keep things informal here as
well as infertile.
That's just a little joke is why
I think Atkinson's purist and often work
is in his stage shows no frills,
just a man and his audience.
These shows make the most of Atkinson's
talents.
The skits are funny,
but the attitude in which they're
performed is the
Jordan tried to keep things in full here
as well as in fertile.
That's just a little joke on,
on names,
anus.
Awesome.
I'm a dick.
You know,
a lot of prospective brides asked me
these days,
father,
what is the church's attitude to
fellatio?
And I tend to reply by telling them a
little story about the first time I was
asked that question.
All jokes that require the performer to
strike the exact right tone
because it's the character that makes
them work,
not the punchlines.
It's the way this freeze cracks the
communion wafer and dips it into the
wine.
It's the dead pan seriousness of this
school master doing a totally absurd
roll call.
It's the way the devil drops his head to
the side with a bit of self deprecation.
The character is the joke.
This is the comedy personality.
It's not about doing funny things.
It's about doing something quite normal
in a funny way
that's actually Atkinson himself acting
in narrating a documentary,
really along video essay on the
principles of visual comedy.
I'll link to it below.
Definitely watched the whole thing in
describing the comedy of personality.
Atkinson is describing what excites him
the most,
but also what he's the best app.
For example,
if you were to take the comedy of
personality to its most extreme,
he probably get a sketch like this one
where Atkinson gives an acting lecture,
portraying a bunch of different
personalities,
Imessenger and just bearing good news
I mentioned to inches
bad news
messenger
and just burying bad news,
which he thinks is good news.
There's really no joke at all here.
Just personalities and personalities
within personalities.
Atkinson is playing his self serious
actor playing various different parts.
The actor is proudly displaying his
talent,
but when something goes wrong,
we get a glimpse of
character underneath and it's even funny
to really grasp and audience with
comedy.
This takes enormous precision and those
who can do it have a style that is
completely inimitable,
which is sort of ironic since being a
physical comedian requires a mastery of
invitation and a minute study of human
behavior.
These comedians find comedy in the
slightest things,
the way someone flicks a wrist or the
way someone pronounces the first letter
in a word and he knew we're feels a
single piano note.
We're signifies a whole nationality with
the tiniest
as well as the Russians.
Generally the things that make me laugh
or characters,
you know,
it's people who kind of present a sort
of truth to you.
I mean even though it's mad or it's
funny or it's wacky or it's rude or it's
though it's silly,
but there's a sort of a truth there that
you identify with and you think that
situation I've been there,
I've seen someone like that on the train
or I am someone like that and I prefer
to keep it hidden.
And yet here,
here I am being characterized extremely
well and that's
one of the questions you guys asked me
all the time is what kind of software I
use to make these videos will to edit.
I use final cut pro 10 and since 10 is
so different from the program that came
before it.
I depended a lot on online videos to
teach me all the new features.
These days you can pretty much teach
yourself anything this way and
skillshare is the perfect way to do it.
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
18,000
classes in graphic design,
animation,
web development,
video game design,
and final cut pro 10.
All the classes are professional and
understandable and follow a clear
learning curve.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses,
but the first 200 people to sign up
using the link in the description.
We'll get your first three months for
just ninety nine cents.
This offer was supposed to be only
available for January,
but skillshare is extending it out for
you guys until February 15th.
In those three months,
you could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business.
What's the skill that you've been
putting off?
Learning?
Checkout,
skillshare.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.